[موسيقى]
القائد الحكيم هو الذي يعرف كيف يتجنب
الحرب لكنه اذا اضطر لها يعرف كيف يقهر
خصمه ولا يبقى مجرد رد فعل لتحركات اعدائه
اهلا بكم في عسكريتا
[موسيقى]
كندا تنهي جدلا استغرق عقدا من الزمن
وتتعاقد رسميا على شراء 88 طائره مقاتله
من طراز اف 35 ايه الامريكيه بقيمه تصل
الى نحو 14 مليارا ومائتين مليون دولار
امريكي في صفقه تعد الاضخم في تاريخ
القوات الجويه الكنديه منذ ثلاثه عقود
مقاتله الجيل الخامس الشبحيه ستحل محل
الاصول الكندي من مقاتلات سي اف 18 ومن
المتوقع ان يبدا تسليم الطائرات بحلول عام
2026 وينتهي بحلول عام 2014
انعكاسا للتهديدات الدوليه الحاليه التي
تلعب فيها الصواريخ دورا ريسيا شركه
رافايل الاسرائيليه اعلنت تطوير منظومه
للدفاع الجوي تسمى سبايدر لتشمل الحمايه
من الصواريخ البالسيه التكتيكيه تطوير
المنظومه يشمل تحديث الاجهزه والبرامج
وصاروخ ديربي ال ار الاعتراضي كما ان
ترقيات الاخيره التي نفذتها الشركه جاءت
بسبب متطلبات العملاء الذين يتعاملون معها
نجحت طائره بوينغ من طراز اف 15 اي اكس اي
جيل تو في احدث اختباراتها في اطلاقه
صاروخين جووا لاستهدافي احدى المسيارات من
محطات اطلاق جديده هذه المحطات تم اضافتها
لطائره بهذه التحديثات تقترب الطائره من
كونها الاكثر قدره على حمل الصواريخ داخل
الاسطول الجوي الامريكي
اكثر حموله للمقاتلات الامريكيه الخليه لا
تتجاوز ثمانيه صواريخ
لم يعد خفيا بان الحرب في اوكرانيا اشعلت
سباق تسلح على مستوى العالم ففي حين مثلا
ضعفت معظم الدول من ميزانيتها الدفاعيه
سرعت العديد من الشركات لتطوير تكنولوجيا
تتماشى مع المتطلبات الجديده للحرب
الحديثه لكن السؤال كيف انعكست هذه الحربه
على الاتجاهات العالميه في الصناعات
العسكريه وهل نحن امام مستقبل جديد
لموازين قوه عالميه مختلفه عن التي ظهرت
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه ام لا هذا ما
سنناقشه مع الباحث في شؤون الدفاع والامن
الدكتور بيتر سنجر بروفيسور دراسات الامن
العالمي في جامعه ولايه اريزونا والباحث
في معهد امريكا الجديده للدراسات اولا همم
اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتاريا فيما يتعلق
بالحرب في اوكرانيا كيف اثرت على
الاتجاهات العالميه في التسلح وبرايه ما
هي اكثر القطاعات داخل الجيوش تاثرا بعد
هذه الحرب
تويتر تويتر
فعاليتها في الحروب التقليديه مثل
المنظومات غير الماهوله او المسيرات التي
استخدمت في الحروب في العراق وافغانستان
مثلا الا ان الهدف الرئيسي من استخدامها
هو مكافحه الارهاب اما في اوكرانيا فقد
اثبتت انها مؤثره وقويه في النزاعات واسعه
النطاق وهذا لا ينطبق فقط على المسيرات
كبيره الحجم مثل المسيرات التركيه بل ايضا
على المنظمات المدنيه الصغيره الامر
الثاني هو ان الحرب تسببت في طلب كبير جدا
للمعاني والذخيره حتى من الجيوش غير
المشاركه في الحرب والدول التي تزوده هذه
المهن مثل امريكا او ايران تعاني لتلبيتها
هذه الطلبات الكبيره في الروس بدات تنفذ
منهم ليس فقط الصواريخ بل ايضا وظائف
المدفعيه والامر المثير الثالث وان البعض
قال ان هناك بعض التكنولوجيا
لم تكن مفيده على الاطلاق مثل الدبابات
التي لم تكن مثيره في الاسابيع الاولى من
النزاع ولكنني اعتقد ان هذا الكلام مبالغ
فيه ولا يعني ذلك ان الدبابات لن يكون لها
دور في الحروب او اننا لن نشهد معارك
بحريه بعد الان بل السبب ان روسيا
استخدمتها بشكل غبي جدا ولذلك فان هذا
الجدل القائمه حول سلاسل لتوريد العالميه
لهذه الاسلحه في النزاعات لن يتحقق وسوف
يستمر بيع الدبابات والسفن القتاليه
الدكتور بيتر افهم من حديث كهذا بانه بعض
الاراء التي خرجت بانه بعض الجيوش بحاجه
الى ترتيب اولوياتها في التسلح بعد ما ظهر
في الحرب في اوكرانيا ليس صحيح على سبيل
المثال ام انه همم بعض الجيوش ما زالت
بحاجه الى اعاده اولوياتها في برامج
التسلق الخاصه بها
الحرب في اوكرانيا وكانها حصه دراسيه او
مختبر بالنسبه لهم وكل دوله تتعلم الدروس
حول ما ينجح وما لا ينجح وكل ما يخص
منظومات الاسلحه وكيفيه استخدامها
وتنظيمها فاستخدام المنظومات غير الماهوله
مثلا اي المسيرات في الحروب التقليديه وفي
هذه المعارك الكبرى دفع كل الجيوش الاخرى
لمراقبه ما يجري وارغمهم على اعاده تقيمهم
لاساليب استخدامه هذه المنظمات وهل عليهم
شراع المزيد منها وكذلك كيفيه الدفاع ضدها
وسوف نشهد زياده كبيره جدا في تكنولوجيا
مكافحه مسيرات جانب اخر هو نوع من التدريب
الذي توفره فمن بين الدروس التي استفادت
بها عده دول حتى الصين على سبيل المثال هو
مستوى ادائي اوكرانيا العالي
روسيا الضعيف والكثير من ذلك له علاقه ليس
فقط بالتنظيم بل بالتدريب ايضا وليس فقط
للضباط بل للمجندين ايضا وسيقود ذلك الى
اجراء تغييرات الدكتور بيتر بالتاكيد
الولايات المتحده كانت تراقب ما يحدث في
اوكرانيا لكن هل بعدما ظهر خلال عام من
الحرب هل باتت الولايات المتحده اكثر ااا
ثقه بقدرتها العسكريه ام ان ما حدث على
ارض الواقع كشف للولايات المتحده نقاط ضعف
لم تكن تاخذها في الحسبان في السابق
اعتقد ان كليهما صحيح فمن جهه كان هناك
شبه خوفا من روسيا وما قد تقوم به في
اوروبا والذي تسبب في الكثير من التخطيط
الدفاعي في امريكا ولكن اتضح ان روسيا
ليست بارعها الكثيرون وقد العاكس ذلك في
امور كثيره مثليين القوات الامريكيه في
اوروبا وحتى ما توقعته الكثيرون حول ما
سيحدث في اوكرانيا لكن مع ذلك بان
المسؤولين العسكريين في امريكا
تعرفون ان الخصم الذي يقلقهم اكثر وهو
الصين يدرس ما يحدث في روسيا ولن يرتكب
نفس الاخطاء هناك سؤال ايضا حول انواع
المنظمات التي احتوت على بعض الثغرات الا
انها اثبتت انها مفيده جدا في اوكرانيا
مثل المسيرات الكبيره وكذلك الصغيره التي
اطلقت بمجموعات كبيره وهذا شيء لم تقم به
امريكا الى ان استخدمها الاوكرانيون
والروس في فاعليه كبيره مما دفع الجيش
الامريكي للتفكير في كيفيه استخدامها
وكذلك كيفيه الدفاع ضدها اذا ما استخدمت
لمهاجمه وحداتها تمام الدكتور بيتر من
انهيار الجدار برلين ونحن امام ملامح
واضحه لموازين القوه في العالم الان هناك
قوى صاعده كثيره سواء الصين او كوريا
الجنوبيه او اليابان او بعض الدول الان
لديها طموحات عسكريه كبيره وكذلك طموحات
اقتصاديه هل تعتقد بانه يعني السنوات
القادمه من الممكن ان يكون هناك موازين
قوه جديده غير المتعارف عليها منذ انهيار
جدار برلين
ببروز الصين ليس فقط كقوه اقتصاديه او
سياسيه بنك قوه عسكريه خارقه ستكون واحده
من اهم قصص القرن الحادي والعشرين
الجيوسياسيه والمساله لا تخص فقط ما ستقوم
به الصين مع هذه القوه الخارقه والنفوذ
التي تسعى لتحقيقه ليس فقط
وجودها المتنامي في كل مكان مثل الشرق
الاوسط وافريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه وكذلك
كيف ستستجيب الدول الاخرى للصيني هل ستسعى
لتحقيق التوازن معها وتشكيل معارضه اذا ما
رات ان الصين تشكل لهم تحديدا ام تنضم
اليها وتكون الصين قادره على جذبهم سواء
عبر المحفزات او التحديدات هذه هي دينا
ملكيه القوه التي تخلط الاوراق ليس اسيا
بل حتى في النقاشات حول ما سيحدث لاحقا في
الشرق الاوسط
الدكتور بيتر الحرب في اوكرانيا اظهرت نوع
جديد من التحالفات العسكريه ربما البعض
يسميها تحالفات الضروره مثل التحالف
العسكري الموجود حاليا ما بين ايران
وروسيا من جانب لكن برايك الى ما اي مدى
هذه التحالفات قادره على الصمود خاصه بانه
مثل هذه التحالفات ليست مبنيه على توافق
فكري او ايديولوجي ما بين الانظمه الحاكمه
لهذه الدول
دقيق فهذه التحالفات قائمه على الصفقات
وهي تركز على المعارضه المشتركه اكثر من
تركيزها على الايديولوجيا او القيم
المشتركه وهذا يشمل العلاقه بين روسيا
وايران او حتى بين روسيا والصين ما تغير
في العام الماضي هو موقف القوه في تلك
العلاقات في العلاقه بين روسيا وايران
مثلا ايران اصبح لديها موقف قوه اعظم
نسبيا من روسيا لانها اصبحت الطرف الذي
يزود روسيا بمنظومات الاسلحه التي تحتاجها
الاخيره وبالتحديد الصواريخ والمسيرات نفس
الشيء ينطبق على الصين حيث كان بوتا يرى
نفسه ندا وشريكا الا انه الطرف الاضعف في
العلاقه وهو مثل الشقيق الاصغر ولقد
شاهدنا ذلك باشكال واضحه للعيان مثل اسلوب
معاملته في القمم العالميه وكذلك باشكالا
تعاملت فيها الصين مع روسيا خلف الكواليس
مثل الاشياء التي وافقت الصين على تزويدها
لروسيا واشياء اخرى رفضت تزويدها لروسيا
وحتى اسعاره شراء الطاقه من روسيا في
الصين كانت متحالفه مع روسيا الا انها في
نفس الوقت استغلت هذه العلاقه بين صحه
تعبير دكتور بيتر سنجر
الجديده شكرا جزيلا على كل ما تفضل به
طائره من المفترض ان تحل خلال السنوات ال
10 المقبله محل مروحيات البلاك هوك
والاباتشي الامريكيه في المهام الهجوميه
بعيده المدى طائرات فيما 280 فلور هذه
الطائره التي تصنعها شركه بيل هليكوبتر
بالتعاون مع شركه توكيد مارتن الامريكيه
وحلقت بالفعل للمره الاولى في عام 2017
هذه الطائره الى
556 كيلو مترا في الساعه في ما يصل مداها
العملياتيه الى
1480 كلم
كما انها مسلحه بمدافع رشاشه وصواريخ
موجهه مضاده للدروع وكذلك صواريخ مضاده
لطائرات فيما ستصل حموله هذه الطائره
القصوى الى
4500 كيلو غرام
[موسيقى]
بعد الفاصل اليابان تضاعفه ميزانيها
الدفاعيه بعد تنام القدرات العسكريه
الصينيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد احدث قرار اليابان
الاخير بمضاعفه ميزانيتها الدفاعيه مع
التركيز على تنميه القدرات الهجوميه احدث
صدمه لدى عده دول في اسيا خاصه ان هذا
الامر يشكل انتهاء سياسه انتاجتها اليابان
منذ انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بامتلاك اسلحه دفاعيه فقط
العديد من الخبراء يعتقدون ان السبب وراء
الخطوه اليابانيه هو تعاضم القدرات
الصينيه العسكريه وعلى الجانب الاخر تنامي
القدرات الصاروخيه لكوريا الشماليه للحديث
اكثر عن تداعيات القرار الياباني وكذلك
التحركات العسكريه الصينيه الاخيره معنا
الباحث في شؤون الدفاع في المركز الدولي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه من لندن السيد
دوغلاس باري اولا مستر دوبل اهلا بك معنا
في عسكريتاريا لماذا اليابان الان تتبنى
ميزانيه عسكريه بهذا الحجم ذات الطبيعه
النوعيه في شكل الاسلحه لاول مره منذ اكثر
من نصف القرن
ما نشهده هو تحول في موقف اليابان الدفاعي
كرده فعل للتطورات الاقليميه والمتطلبات
الامنيه المتزايده الصين تحولت من مصدر
وخلال السنوات الماضيه استمرت كوريا
الشماليه بكونها مشكله وكذلك روسيا اما
الاسلحه سواء كانت دفاعيه او هجوميه
فالامر يخص النوايا اكثر مما يخص القدرات
فاصواريخ الكروز بعيده المدى على سبيل
المثال يمكن ان تعدى اسلحه دفاعيه في اطار
الردع التقليدي وجديد بالذكر ان اليابان
بدات تكمل علاقتها الدفاعيه الواطيده
بالولايات المتحده عبر علاقات متلامنيه مع
بريطانيا
ومشاركتها في برنامج المستقبلي للطائرات
القتاليه مع لندن وروما
ليس خفيا بان هناك سباق تسلح منذ فتره في
القاره الاسيويه لكن بعد خطوه اليابان هل
تعتقد بان حده هذا السباق ستزداد بعد
القرار الياباني الاخير
اعتقد ان هناك عناصر لسباق التسلح في
المنطقه وعلى الرغم من ان هذا المصطلح
يولد التوترات دون ايجاد الحلول لكن
تحصينا اليابان لقدرتها واعاده رسمتها قد
يولدوا رده فعل صينيه على سبيل المثال
بخلاف ان ما تقوم به طوكيو هو رده فعل
لتحديث الصين لجيشها وتعزيز موقفها
العدواني اضافه الى التطورات الحاصله في
كوريا الشماليه وروسيا
مستر دوبلاس على مدى سنوات قدمت الصين
نفسها كقوه اقتصاديه الان يبدو ان لديها
برامج تسحيه تختلف عن البرامج السابقه
اللي بكين برايك ما هي اولويات التسلح
الان التي يعني تريد بكين ان تتمتع بها في
المستقبل
التقليدي سنشهد استثمارات المستمره في
المجالات الجويه والفضائيه والبحريه وفي
نطاق الجوي وهو مجال الاقتصادي خلال
العقود قليله المنصارمه انتقلت الصين من
موقفها كقوه محدوده جدا الى قوه جويه ذات
قدره عاليه جدا
وتحولت من اعتمادها على التصاميم الروسيه
الى الانتاج المحلي ولديها القاعده
الصناعيه التكميليه لدعم كل ذلك مثال على
ذلك هو القوات الجويه الصينيه التي لديها
الان مئه وخمسون طائره من نوع شندول جي 20
القتاليه المتطوره جدا اما روسيا
بالمقارنه فقد انتجت 10 فقط من طائرات
سوخوي 57 المكافئه اما فيما يخص القدره
النوويه فان بكين على ما يبدو تبتعد عن
موقف للرضع الادنى بهدف الوصول الى مستوى
الولايات المتحده مع مرور الوقت والبحريه
الصينيه قدمت صاروخا ماليزيا يطلق من
الغواصات والقوات الجويه تؤدي دور النوويه
كما تطور الصين ثلاثه من الصين لاطلاق
الصواريخ العابره للقارات
فيما يتعلق بتيوان
يعني كثيرا ما حذرت الصين من احتماليه
استقلال تايوان
اعتقد رايك بانه الصين على مقربه من اتخاذ
خطوات عسكريه لضمه تايوان مثلا
قائما اما مدى احتماليه حدوث ذلك فيعتمد
على اسلوب تفكيرنا متفائل ام متشائم
هناك الكثير من التحالفات في منطقه بحر
الصين الجنوبي وكذلك في منطقه المحيط
الهادئ لكن برايك هذه التحالفات التي
تقودها بشكل او باخر الولايات المتحده هي
كافيه لردع بكين عن اي نوايا سواء فيما
يتعلق بتيوان او فيما يتعلق باي دوله اخرى
من حلفاء الولايات المتحده
وكذلك لاعب دوري الردعي في وجهه الصين ان
تكون مؤثره مؤخرا مستر دوبلاس بعض الدول
التي كانت تعتمد على الولايات المتحده مثل
كوريا الجنوبيه وكذلك اليابان
يبدو وكانها تريد ان يكون لديها صناعه
دفاعيه خاصه بها هل هذا القرار نابع من
تخوف من اعتمادهم على الولايات المتحده ام
ان يريدون ان يقيموا شراك دفاعيه مع
الولايات المتحده شراكه منضبطه ليس فقط
تعتمد على الولايات المتحده وعلى قرار
البيت الابيض بشكل اخر
اعتقد انه من الطبيعي للدول ان تطور
قدرتها العسكريه وقواعدها الصناعيه
الدفاعيه وتسعى لزياده قدره الانتاج
الوطني في نفس الوقت الذي تبقى فيه
الولايات المتحده شريكا اقليميا مهما كما
ترون فعلى الرغم من ان اليابان توصل
علاقتها بريطانيا وايطاليا عبر برنامج
طائرات قتاليه فهي لم تقطع علاقاتها مع
اميركا فعلاقتها مع بريطانيا وايطاليا
مكمله لعلاقتها المستمره مع امريكا
باري البحث في شؤون الدفاع في المركز
الدولي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا
كنت معنا من لندن
مع تطور السلاح المدفعيه وتغير شكل
المعارك ظهرت الحاجه الى الحفاظ على
الاسناد الناري للجيوش بالتزامن مع
تحركاتها السريعه هذا بغض النظر عن طبيعه
ارض المعركه كل هذه المتطلبات افضت الى
ظهور السلاح الجديد المدافع ذاتيه الحركه
هذه المدافع عباره عن مدافع هوتزر محموله
على هياكل الدبابات بحيث توفر اسنادا
ناريا سريعا ومتواصلا يتواكبوا مع تقدم
القوات البريه على الارض تتميز المدافع
ذاتيه الحركه بقدرتها على اخذ الوضعيه
القتاليه واطلاق النيران خلال دقائق قليله
او حتى خلال ثواني معدوده هذه طبعا على
عكس مدافع الهودزر التقليديه والتي بحاجه
الى نقلها الى ارض المعركه وتجهيزها
للاطلاق اهم ما يميز مدافع الهوت ذاتيه
الحركه هو القدره على تغيير موقعها بعد كل
عمليه اطلاق نار هذا الامر يصعد من عمليه
او حتى استهدافها او الظهور لمدافع الهاود
زر ذاتيه الحركه كان خلال الحرب العالميه
الاولى بعد ما قامت بريطانيا بوضع مدفع
عيار 25 ملي متر على ظهر احدى دباباتها
منذ هذه اللحظه باتت مدافع الهوت زر ذاتيه
الحركه جزء اساسيا من سلاح المدفعيه في
الجيوش الحديثه كما ان هذه المدافع لعبت
وما زالت تلعب دورا بارزا على سبيل المثال
الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا التي تدور
حاليا حيث تمكن الجيش الاوكراني من تعذيزي
مواقع في الشرق والجنوب بفضل مدافع الهوت
زر ذاتيه الحركه والتي حصل عليها من عده
دول غربيه
[موسيقى]
حلقه عسكري تريقه لهذا الاسبوع قد انتهت
الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد
من الصفقه في امان الله
[موسيقى]